can you understand why i had the biggest
crush ever on chain west come on
mandy moore takes a sweet trip down
memory lane or maybe we should say a
walk to remember will you go out with me
yep the iconic romance just turned 20
and in honor of its anniversary mandy
gave the millennial favorite flick a
watch
hi friends so today marks the 20th
anniversary of a walk to remember being
in theaters and documented it all on
tick tock i haven't seen the movie in
over a decade and i can't think of a
better way to celebrate than to watch
the movie with all of you a little mood
lighting
just in case
in her mini blog mandy looks back at
some of the movie's most memorable
moments
[Music]
[Music]
and how about this
[Music]
jamie sullivan herself gracing us with
that angelic voice
[Music]
mandy goes on to ask a question that
really needs no explanation it's more
like figuring out what you're gonna do
when you get somewhere i mean
can you understand why i had the biggest
crush ever on chain west come on
and she caps off her vid with a
passionate battle cry
about life
hope and a long journey ahead
jamie and landon forever
mandy's a walk to remember family is all
about her tribute which she posted to
instagram too where shane west commented
this is the best thing ever while
director adam shankman wrote holy
you just made me cry
mandy also shared this throwback
snuggled up with shane and adam during
production
a to remember is not a teen movie in
fact to me i think it's the antithesis
to teen movies that are out here today
chatting with et at the time mandy and
shane joked about filming their first
kissing scene so the first day that i
showed up on set i knew shane he was
more of an acquaintance and stuff like
that but you have to
kiss this person that you don't know
very well and you don't even have a
friendship with yet so that's always
awkward in front of you know 200 people
that are in the crew
mandy was a bit uh she was a bit nervous
in the beginning i remember especially i
think the first day we had to do one of
our kissing scenes and um
i became nervous for her and then
nervous for myself and just in the
situation i think it helped with the
the awkward kisses that we had but
besides that it's okay i mean it's not
bad to kiss a cute boy i guess
[Music]